le troisième des grands optimaux reus et
patrick il a 16 ans faisant rue comment
peut-on concilier le métier de jeunes
acteurs et de et d'étudier en quoi c'est
facile aux russes se fasse une toute
manière il faut avoir des répétiteurs
non et quand on loue parcourront le
rattrape un peu tôt m j'aime à méditer
c'était un droit strict que personne au
monde ne peux m'empêcher d'exercer
toujours un truc c'est très très très
très mauvais parce qu'on n'a pas répété
ça finit par devenir un peu meilleur ce
que je suis à chomedey à force de jouer
devant les gens ont fini par trouver tf1
bien me comme également la boîte
critiques qui sont venus qui les ont
massacrés au départ on a le temps de se
remettre sur le calme une bonne
méditation demande pour être profitable
une sorte d'état de grâce
dans le respect du client quand même il
a une double occlusion intra duodénal
par suite de perforation sous
pancréatiques en étoile avec
l'éclatement dernière d'où épanchements
de matières fécales et adhérence au
péritoine d'un pliage accordéon suspect
vraisemblablement du papier hygiénique
mais quelques têtes ce merdier
et quand tu seras grand que les la
profession que tu désires exercer
opérateurs effectivement c'est une
profession parallèle à celle de comédien
merci